okay hello and welcome to this video the
software was a bit strange there yeah
this video his feature in game 10 of the
World Championship match between Magnus
Carlsen defending champion and
Challenger Sega coyoacán ya que apenas
leading by one point that Carlton
desperately needs to win one of the
remaining three games to at least level
the match and get to a tiebreaker and
while he has two white games left so
this game with white game 10 is one of
the absolute key moments and chances for
the defending champion to do something
um I wasn't quite sure what he was going
to play me there are some choices there
he lost with default with the color in
the last white game and he returns to
1.e4 we caught a spanish window pass so
no sidelines like I know the scotch or
something um problem in critical
situation it's not an it's not a bad
choice to go to something where you feed
at home and not try something that is
completely out of your usual water sled
team and we see that kayak in sticks
here with the Berlin this is oh let's
check actually let's think about it did
we had we had a build an earlier right
that was game Game three year was a
villain yeah back then in this game
cousin opted for this variation but this
time he goes for d3 yeah the Berlin
ending it's probably a bad choice a d3
just keeps more tension on the board
Bishop c5 and c3 yeah what can also take
on sea sickness is also align that
Carlton has played here this one quite
successfully but probably here he wants
to just keep a bit more attention on the
bored castle spire kayaking and Carson
Wentz goes for Bishop g5 and this is not
so common you might usually castles in
this position but of course them they
have been a dozens of games with this as
well well h6 Bishop h4 and now I think
an interesting decision by the
Challenger it's a well known motive and
probably also quite well known in this
particular position is the move Bishop
to e7 actually think that Carlton has
played this in a game against shear off
some years ago I can't remember this
game um yeah Bishop d7 it looks a bit
stranger black moves the bishop again he
had it on c5 and now it's going back to
87 and it is however making quite some
sense because you want to break the spin
this pin was very annoying and usually
you need to go g5 to get rid of it and
this is not the kind of decision you you
are very comfortable with in many cases
once you have castle so Bishop e7 is
conservative but a good move Castle TI
could have wide taken the pawn this is
something that you always have to check
in what about this and white grab this
pawn usually you cannot do that because
of d 5 which is opening up the position
in the center against White's king in
this case there's even this tactic again
looking at this Bishop and if white
takes oops greene takes here the night
is hanging so here black is even better
so castles must play it d6 and night BTW
2nite h5 this is the key idea with this
Bishop e7 move after unpinning black
gets to trade this Bishop and this is
something that is quite nice for black
it's it's an accomplishment to trade
this piece one reason is that you gain
a good square for the Queen black is
having slightly less space just a little
bit less space and like one or two piece
trades are quite welcome um the white
strategy in this game those the slow
kind of position reminded me a little
bit of that final game in 1987 when
because far-off needed a win against
Karpov to level the match and the
Kasparov chose a very very slow opening
like a ratty system with be 3g 3 III
such a very very slow buildup kind of
game and i think carlton strategy was a
bit similar in that regard just play a
very slowish position with with small
nuances we're kayaking does not have a
clear path to just let say trade pieces
or do something very straightforward but
you have to maneuver a little bit an
idea for I mean black is okay I'm not
saying that white is much better just
that it's a somewhat undefined position
where you don't have a clear path to
just like try to a trade okay night air
for that night has a good square them
right back to e3 that was the idea of 94
while it looks at those crucial squares
Queen f6 playback kayaking that also
kinda normal move like could have played
f5 he actually it's something that the
engines quite like but it's not really
in the style of the Challenger and
especially not if you're leading in the
match however and this kind of strategy
to like always avoid any complications
and it's something that is also in my
view a little bit one-dimensional so at
one point you have to play some active
moves okay anyway this is not like the
best move or much better than what you
did is just like this is the general
kind of strategy that he has played but
he has been so successful with it so
it's something that we have to accept in
some way
okay Queen jf 6g three you need to do
something about this night you cannot
just stuck tolerated her own f4 for a
long time and here at least it puts the
night all this weird square I mean okay
black did not need to go there they
could it could have gone back it's not
like this this losers but why it is
definitely more comfortable here yeah
something like you can even think about
D for him you have just expand in the
center I didn't analyze this move
actually I'm just thinking about it now
because night h3 looks kind of normal
but the night just also I mean liability
is strong but black has to watch out for
this piece it's a little bit off so King
edge 197 yes this is also something that
is quite common in those positions the
knight on c6 was looking at those
covered squares and wants to regroup
yeah Bishop c4 plate bye-bye Carlton
okay i can when c6 after a very long
thing and i think this is a good
indication that Carlton's choice of
position type wasn't wasn't a bad one
because it is clearly and i said a bit
undefined what black wants to do a or
should do him and kayaking was spending
quite a good amount of time so we should
be three just like okay show me what you
want to do with 96 again after some some
thoughts queen to eat too yeah this is
actually a normal-looking move but one
thing we have to keep in mind that there
is a critical square on a form so
whenever I mean I really think there is
something that I'm not sure if there is
a term for that is there's something
like described in a book but I always
feel like
pickle strikes they often happen on
squares that are multiplied attacked or
controlled by a piece like here you put
the Queen only two you should always be
aware that there are two nights pointed
to f4 so let's say a black wanted I want
to do anything identified right yeah so
here on a very trivial no yes something
like that loses a queen and it's
something that you have to keep in mind
if many pieces point toward one square
like here in there for four pieces if
you count the pawn directed toward x
square you have to watch our for tactics
on that square and in particular here it
is very obvious that Kingi 2nite f4 is a
tactic but there are far more complex
situations where the same thing applies
it's something that I noticed over the
years maybe there's also some kind of
term for that that is in a book that I'm
not aware of but Jamie it happens quite
often I think okay a form to stop any
black expansion and the bishop 36 a very
logical move yeah and here cousin took a
very surprising decision and something
that could have had very far-reaching
consequences and what he probably should
do here is to play to play a slow move
here like maybe 92 or Bishop see to one
of the two men this is probably not a
bad choice I mean we have to know that
the pawn structure is almost completely
symmetrical the only differences on the
King side and why it is a little bit
more comfortable really just a tiny bit
more comfortable because of this
slightly awkward night so white ideally
here could long-term try to maybe let's
say plane I g2f for something like that
with the Black Knight being subject or
being kicked around and why do getting
more and more tired
what is what counts is played is Bishop
takes is 6 and the problem with this
move is a technical one black took with
the pawn opening up the F file and
Carlton went 9-2 d2 and here we come to
an absolutely critical position of this
game early on here okay i can after not
not long thought plate the movie 5 now
here the clocks a little bit also it
looks like he he gained time and that
that's wrong but he played this very
quickly and instead he could have plated
the move Knight takes f to check and
it's very surprising that he decided on
d5 so quickly of course I'm in thousand
thought form 10 minutes on 92 so it was
not like he could think about this
before and but it's still surprising
that he did not consider night x f2 more
carefully ok let's have a look what
would have happened ok the King has to
move and we have to we have to see that
okay there are two most Kings you want
this is just the check check and black
here just as 1 upon so that doesn't make
any sense so King g2 yeah sorry King g2
and now we come to this this is this key
a tactical idea tonight a check for
check this is the thing if white now
takes it Queen g6 sched win for black
the White King has no squares so my
Carlton would have had to move the King
again and we have a check here and this
is going to take a potential check check
the only way here for what to to deviate
would be
would be let's go what was it actually
after this there was this [ __ ] f form
my notes are confusing so Kim Ji Won
okay I up was sorry step into G 2 in
this position yeah I'm sorry yeah so
King g2 and now of course black has to
form an air form and this leads to a
very weird position takes can I takes
root eggs context and the y tonight
needs to move probably to see to step
necessary can also go to see for ya at
this position then we have rook black
has a look at two points those two
points against two nights and usually
this should favor the side with the with
the rook rook and pawn against two
pieces often already quite ok for the
rook and two pawns sounds great this
position ever is not entirely clear
because white has some pretty decent
blockading chances against the pawns and
you should not underestimate the power
of two pieces simply two nights against
the single rook if white manages to get
some good outposts for his nights he can
actually be quite ok so it's not clear
to me of kayaking rejected this
possibility that he did not like to play
this unbalanced type of position or if
he had some miscalculation sorry I'm
kind of hitting this by accident even if
there was some kind of miscalculation
here because he definitely did not avoid
a draw I mean he would have be delighted
to draw into any moves here with black
so it's kind of unclear what was missed
[Music]
he played d5 and and now Carlton takes
an interesting decision he played
Queen age five and the thing is it still
allows 19f to but this is not as clear
as it was before and um it's it's it's a
bit of them I'm not sure if it was a was
a conscious gamble or not because it is
qin age five it's the best move if black
does not take on f2 let's say it's
better than f3 or any other move that
would just stop any business on f2 so
okay he could have taken on f2 again but
this is a different story now child
takes on f2 and kingi to King King g1 is
answered by this strong move that's a
key key idea why it takes it and check
oops black remains upon up so the King
would have had to go here and now we
come to the to the tricky part the move
Queen jf seven this is a key resource
threatening night F for winning the
Queen and yeah very very difficult
situation now Kim Ji Won is a tricky
move getting out of the checks and here
the weird thing is that black here would
lose if he does any black has to find
one particular move Queen GF 6 this is
the only move that does not lose funny
enough but that does work yet again
threatening Queen g5 and why not
probably I mean right can repeat now
with King g2 that would be another draw
but it's not necessary I mean why it can
play on it can play a move like I mean
black is not you just has to address
Queen g5 summer let's say I think even
h4 was an idea and oh yeah actually 9f
voice good i'm sorry but look you want
ahead and move that you could continue
with
me check nodes are a total mess yeah
look a 181 was something that white
could have played so i would i would
actually understand if you if you would
reject this position with black kayaking
did not go for it he played 95 instead
going back however this clearly
constitute some kind of admission that
black is worse contemplate age four and
now you have to go to have three there
is no other way i cannot cannot
seriously consider to go back and why
this going here and the point is is
falling already so Knight f3 check and
now we get to this ending and this
ending is very uncomfortable for black
if you own give this to to an engine it
will just claim a very slight advantage
for wide and it might be like completely
mathematically speaking not all that
much but in a practical game it's pretty
torturous i mean when i saw this
position during the live broadcast there
was some discussion in the shed about
how this game might progress i was
predicting that white would win this
game it's it's very one-sided I mean we
have to this happened next it's very
one-sided and exactly the kind of
position that that cousin of course
loves to play of course he has failed in
those situations earlier in the match
but you won't fail you won't feel every
time then that that's not that's not
very likely to happen so I was pretty
optimistic here for four white in this
position um the next move um route to
you one look strategically completely
normal but is
probably slightly inaccurate slightly
inaccurate but it was not and used by
kayak and he played h5 this is a move
that you probably cannot avoid in the
long run because white playing age five
you know himself is too annoying yeah
I'm pushing the night back and then the
night coming to g4 is a little bit too
annoying and it's um it's not a very
beautiful move but probably necessary in
the long run strategically speaking but
he had this move and this would have
asked Carlton whatever Ruby one is an f2
attacked yeah the funny thing is if
white now place a completely normal
looking move look to you too there is a
tactic black can take and if wydra
captures there is no chat forum and
black is all of a sudden completely fine
using oops this fork trick I mean white
is not worse he can play this for
example and be okay but yes giving away
all is advantage that it certainly had
um it's funny right actually can
continue to play it just by not taking
this pawn and just play like this this
is funny the computer actually still
likes white here at least a little bit
but here this is what the engine gives
is two points down but he will pick pick
those up but in the process we will get
so much stuff traded that black will
draw up very easily here probably Rookie
of eight was a was an opportunity of
course any causal can even play this
move this is not totally terrible you
can you can kind of regroup but
definitely I mean this should have been
played by black
you played age five though and yeah now
everything is in order the night is on
the way to go to g5 we can put this on
the board that regrouping and here's
this is a good moment to take stock and
kind of explain a little bit why this is
such an uncomfortable position for black
it's uncomfortable because you're stuck
with an inferior porn structure and it's
very difficult to see how black would
actually improve that structure often a
slightly inferior structure like a
double pawn or so it's not such a big
deal if you can improve it or if the
weaknesses cannot be attacked all that
easily and in this position here it's
quite uncomfortable because black is
there is no way that black will get rid
of his double porn the double D pawns
why it always has the opportunity here
to it at the right moment that take on
d5 and attack the e5 point is one thing
and there is this inferior structure on
the Kings side with the whole on g5 so
what has 95 at all times and again black
has no decent um kind of porn lever
anything that would improve his position
while white has a ton of options he has
the capture on d5 to open up the e-file
he has the move deform I like you can
sometimes take he and put pressure here
you can play d4 to make progress this is
what happens in the game or you can play
B form in some cases to open up the
Queen side and the addition of all those
possibilities means that white can yeah
improve a little bit and try around with
no risks well black is basically stuck
with the purely passive defense this is
a sin
usually the the role of the roles that
we usually had in the match kayaking
willing to accept somewhat somewhat
inferior position and defend the
tenacious lame and cars are trying to
make something out of the better
positions which is what frustrated him I
guess a lot that he could not get a win
against them yeah a couple of couple is
strong every two or three of those
positions um against those like passive
somewhat inferior position that he
couldn't couldn't break through so this
is the kind of okay another chance to do
that so Nyjah 57 it doesn't really make
sense to analyze this move by move white
is trying to improve and chooses the
default break this is an opening up the
position in the middle and gets rid of
the demo porn so you could question this
decision but because it helps black to
get rid of one of the weaknesses but
this is a trade off as it often is a
black of course has to take and t2 with
the night and now we see the trade off
the night is position on g4 and black
cannot kick it away with see 5 or a 5 as
that would leave far too many weaknesses
behind or just straight straight away do
set I mean this is check happy move and
NC 5 is also entirely right after the
check black will lose stuff in the in
the middle here look at this just a
terrible situation so the night has a
strong position on deform and we see
condens idea which ended here he's
gained a space there in the middle and
sorry here we see that black is stuck
now with a different set of weaknesses
the pawn is on g6 that was played to
cover f5 but this is giving what an
additional idea g6 week e 6 week and you
have the before push
it's going to be happen soon first
brought the rook them and by the way
something that I'm keep keep explaining
in videos is that Carson did not picture
here a grand winning plan like what what
do i do a 20 moves but usually you make
those little plans those mini plans like
first let's get the route to have six
tickle him a little bit there g6e six
and then see what happens it's usually a
step-by-step process so don't often in
your own games and it often it's this a
good idea to just make small plants
improves improve slowly and try around a
little but don't try to spend 20 minutes
to find some kind of ingenious maneuver
that is like 20 moves deep and it's very
rarely that this is even exists so just
try to do simple things that improve
your position which is seven and now
before being played yeah so black he
says to take this and now we see the
next step what white has managed him is
to get this additional possibility here
it's a very uncomfortable position for
black really very uncomfortable and it
is also difficult him to to do anything
else but a passive defense Kraken is
very good at those passive defenses like
fortresses and kind of simply hard to
find them set up that holds but here I
mean this is really rarely anything else
you just have to sit in sit tight and
defend without having any active and
inactive prospects so now g8 returned
and a5 being played they are securing
the c5 square you know of course why
does not want to trade and now whens
went to see five so King went over here
let's take stock what our wives ideas
YTM mostly has two ideas he has to move
b5 that actually that could have been
not here because of the four but I'm
just I'm just showing it this is the
general idea to break through here it
doesn't work out because there's the for
Conda form but this is the first I'd yet
open up the queenside um can we maybe me
yeah here here's a well-positioned to
show it without blundering stuff because
carbon played the MOOC t3 to cover that
square so like b5 is one plan it's not
very effective here but i just want to
show it this opens up the B file so that
be seven is attackable and one white
wants to do also is route to be six to a
techie six so usually you need more than
one weakness to win your game and here
black has a couple like e6 g6 b7 so this
points toward white having very serious
winning chances in general so b5 is one
idea to get at the weaknesses and the
other a little bit more complicated idea
to make progress would be king h3 f 3g
for push the fif night away if the Black
Knight would need to retreat passively
to something like g7 that would be
pretty bad so those two ideas combining
them is what the kayak in here and has
to face look a 3d form we enter a
maneuvering face countless doing this
very slowly and this is how we do it
don't rush things at night h6 f3 we are
introducing this possibility of g4 look
f7 is a clever little movie energy for
now check quite embarrassing but set of
course rooty force plate just keeping
everything yeah look h7 this is what sky
Atkins idea with Rouen h7
he is ready to yet to prevent you from
like here check blunders the house so
cards when ruby three again hinting at
be five rook to e7 so this is chi Atkins
defensive set up this room protect c6
and they both protect b7 yeah it is a it
is a a good setup definitely um we're
nearing the critical phase as I said
just a couple of moves before the most
60 time control Carlton played route to
d3 he could have played be five in this
position already after txt black has
this defensive idea it's very important
idea the night on c4 looks at five a
five and b6 so this was a key a key
motif contemplate this move it looks
very innocent right what does that move
doing is he just waiting no is actually
covering the square this move does make
perfect sense kayaking now played route
back to age 8 and Carlton shuffled back
okay I can play drew cage seven again
and now this is this is really from a
practical point of view very nice he
just rupee one is a waning move and rook
age seven is the kind of the natural
move you would play because it just is
like a shuffle yeah why this shuffling
back you shuffle back but this is not
like white hasn't done anything he has
put the roof on v3 kayaking ed played
route 287 and this proved to be actually
the losing mistake it looks like nothing
much but this is actually losing the
game he had to absolutely had to now
change tech and yeah play play this move
I know it sounds good but you will see
after be five white is crashing through
this is actually I'm still very very
tough why it has all those advantages as
described but it might not be enough to
win if he now tries to break through
there is this one and this is very
important and there's this additional
move now and from age seven you cannot
go to see eight now this is the thing
now be five was played just before the
second time control breaking through and
now we see the problem there is no root
C seven or whatever in black black now
is faced with rupee six the night he has
no squares this is what rock d three
dead now it controls this whites
position is perfectly coordinated now
yeah kayaking nope lady form doesn't
really have a move and after this we see
it collapses Hanks is attacked week yeah
if you can you can only protect one now
you can do this but then actually this
is stronger even than group 64 yeah
there's a six yeah that's what I thought
like picks up the porn but you can
actually even go here and then play a
six yeah okay he tried Luke c7 and
Carlton took the pawn Group C 3 nidec
form that was more 61 the time control
was was was done the second one yeah
white is 1 upon but it is a very
important point is six pawn so that he
has a passer that you porno is free to
go ng6 is under heavy fire yeah can I
can't ride route to c7 and yeah here why
it has two ways to win the the move that
Carlton played is enough to win he
played the move
Knight to g5 technical solution in a way
rook takes g6 was also sufficient i was
i was actually very impressed at this
point with them with with an engine yeah
if you if you give this position to them
after 95 let's let's look at this 95
it's a fork TX takes this position if
you look at this with the with a stock
fish engine on a regular computer ever
fairly quick normal great core desktop
so it's not super super high end but but
pretty okay and it gives Y term like 1.5
or something so you kind of suspect that
it could be a win but in those awesome
in those endings we're pawns dwindle
down point count sometimes this is
misleading what the engine is giving
anyway like 1.5 but if you if you give
this to a extremely strong engine yeah
there's an online engine that is that
can be checked during during the games
if you want to check it check it out
yourself during the games that you have
to google as s er s e SS e the URL is
essa dot something SE SS e um this is a
40 core system 40 course and this is
giving like plus 80 or so for whites
yeah after a relatively quick time so
the engine says basically assist that
white is cleaning a pawn in the future
and like whatever 25 moves so this is a
crazy how how quick this engine gets to
such a calculation depth that white is
totally winning in the game actually
it's not in an actual game between
humans it's still a little bit tricky
and how I can play this it's the best
move Knight b5 back and King to see 8
this is still somewhat tricky in this
position here causal spend a couple of
minutes and try and now try to calculate
it all the way to the end and you did so
successfully there is in fact only one
way to win I mean it's not superhuman to
find it but you still have to play it
yeah you took on g6 and after Luke takes
kingi to this is the most precise way of
doing it um the black rook is attacked
and it has no other option than to move
on the third rank after which 96 m gets
to a root ending you always have to be
very very circumspect when you go to
look at name because the drawing margin
in those end games is usually very high
sometimes even cannot win with two extra
points in some unlucky cases he however
it is a fairly straightforward when the
white rook will pick up the deep pawn
and the White King ultimately will enter
here in them again we had rookie 3e six
kings e7 and here we see the point the
white rook is very nicely positioned on
the fifth rank it covers this one and
takes this one and white is now entering
with the king and after King f6 here
Callie I can resign the game so the
match is now tied with the five points
each for both players so what we have
now is a mini match of two games there
are just two games left kayaking will
have white in Game 11 and the cars will
have white in game 12 something that I
actually think I mean it's not a huge
advantage from the minute ism there's a
drawing of lots at the beginning who's
getting white and in what game and
having white in the final game I think
is a slight advantage anyway so two
games left Carlton has leveled the score
and I think this psychologically is a is
extremely good of course when he first
of all he's got the point to level the
match but he also has won his first game
in game 10 yeah if someone would have
predicted that Carlton is not winning a
single
game out of ten games or nine games and
then breaking through on game 10 it
probably would have earned lots of money
and some kind of if you can can can bet
on that it kind of reminded me a little
bit of the London match in two thousand
records brought off didn't score win
against chrome neck and he was yeah I
mean almost visibly falling apart like
why am I not winning a game I should win
a game somewhere I mean it's probably
this is probably something something for
for people with the neck for statistics
when was the last time that Carlton has
not won nine games in a row in classical
chest that probably must have been like
10 years ago if it had ever happened I
mean nine games in a row without a win
that stuff that's very tough so we asked
one this phone this is first game in
this match um if you want me to make a
prediction i think carlton we win this
match now but it's just my my personal
take on it i think he needed this kind
of this kind of boost to just have one
again and be kind of in the match now
what we have to say about this game
whatever is it all hang about on one or
two situations colin did not play
perfectly especially in the beginning he
didn't play it when at all allowing
night f2 and so on um however he played
very well now this time in the technical
phase of the game like everything that
happened from move from here yeah okay
yet this rookie one was also slide in
accuracy but everything after that was
basically perfect play and this is
certainly a good sign for the fans of
the world champion um yeah conducting
again um kind of accepted and passively
and a position that was maybe it was
defender well I don't know maybe there
is some way to defend this position and
but it was a very unattractive
proposition and if you do that like all
of the time you're going to get hit at
some point yeah i think it was
interesting game i hope you enjoyed the
coverage
I have to say something here on personal
note I'm traveling to a tournament the
coming weekend and that means the the
game game 11 that will be played on
saturday i probably will only be able to
cover on sunday evening when i'm
returning from the tournament game 11
will be played on saturday then there
will be resting on sunday and game 12
will be played on monday possible
tiebreaks then we'll be on the wednesday
after that on the 30th so um yeah I can
only cover things from from from home
I'm not taking all my equipment with me
to a tournament so sunday evening will
be probably the time when i'm going to
cover game 11 yeah we can definitely
look forward to very tense two games
thanks for watching this video bye bye